telle matin yves calvi
7h44 merci beaucoup d'écouté rtl
elizabeth martichoux recevait donc ce
matin le président de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes et président des
républicains
laurent wauquiez qui présageait qui
répondra aux questions des auditeurs
avec vous tout à l'heure à 8h20 et qui
pour l'instant répondre à nos question
bonjour laurent ok merci d'être sur rtl
ce matin en présentant les conclusions
du grand débat edouard philippe lebru
ministre a souligné hier la tolérance
fiscale 0 des français il l'a dit on
veut baisser et baisser plus vite les
impôts vous saluer logiquement cette
annonce puisque c'est aussi votre
programme vous en souvenez peut-être
mais quand on avait fait une interview
septembre dernier avant la crise des
filets jaunes je vous avais précisément
dit il ya trop d'impôts en france ça ne
passe plus et on a des classes moyennes
qui sont asphyxiés donc si votre
question c'est est-ce que je me réjouis
que ce qu'on a proposé fini par être
entendu
est ce que le gouvernement ne faisait
pas soit aujourd'hui annoncé par le
premier ministre et bien sûr je n'ai pas
changé d'avis mois mais permettez moi
quand même une remarque quand comment où
quels impôts quel rythme ça fait quand
même quatre mois de débats et on a un
premier ministre qui fait son premier
discours sans aucun élément concret ni
aucune précision savoir max et emmanuel
macron qui va porter les annonces c'est
dans l'ordre institutionnel c'est dans
l'ordre institutionnel aussi quand même
que le premier ministre
après autant de temps commence à mettre
des choses sur la table leur joie qu'ils
jouent avec pourquoi toujours avec le
temps pourquoi est ce que je vous dis ça
parce que le débat a porté au début un
apaisement
le danger c'est que si la sortie du
grand débat n'est pas à la hauteur des
attentes
cet apaisement se transforme en grande
déception et hier c'était pas à la
hauteur on a un premier ministre qui a
enchaîné des banalités sans qu'il y ait
aucune précision normalement au bout de
quatre mois de débat on ne doit plus en
être là que le président de la
république se réserve les annonces
certes mais que maintenant on est des
éléments concrets direction qu'on nous
dise
quels impôts ou comment quelles dépenses
publiques on épargne pour financer ces
baisses d'impôts au stade où on en est
c'est maintenant indispensable alors
c'est indispensable c'est dans quelques
jours
d'après ce que dit l'elysée ce sera la
semaine prochaine donc vous n'avez plus
très longtemps à temps ni les français
vous dites des banalités baisser les
impôts et les baisser vite vous vous
avez vos propositions nous l'avait
encore rappelé récemment elles ne sont
pas de toute façon nouvelle vous baisser
de 10% les impôts pour tous dans votre
programme d'abord ce que vous répétez
encore il ya quelques jours je vais
évidemment vous répondre et c'est oui et
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
juste un point on a voulu faire des
propositions parce qu'on a considéré
contrairement à d'autres partis que
notre responsabilité c'était pas dans
l'opposition secteur pourquoi est-ce que
ce matin je suis exigeant parce que
précisément s'est impliqué dans le débat
et qu'on a mis des chaussures
l'attaquant parfois sur le revenu baisse
des impôts pour tous je vous dis ça
parce que il ya un sentiment et vous le
savez d'injustice fiscale dans le pays
bien sûr c'est ce qui est vous savez
qu'elle est l'or et et vous fait sortir
sans doute plus de français de l'impôt
avec une baisse de 10% mais certains
pourraient vous dire vous faites aussi
un cadeau aux riches
vous savez ce qui me choque pas tant
notre débat français ont dit on va taxer
les plus riches et à la région tac
surtout les classes moyennes
pourquoi est-ce que je veux que ce soit
une baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu pour
tous parce que les principales victimes
de l'impôt sur le revenu c'est les
classes moyennes le gouvernement a agité
une proposition consistant à dire on va
baisser l'impôt sur le revenu mais
seulement pour les plus modestes
ben moi je considère qu'il faut arrêter
d'oublier systématiquement ceux qui sont
au milieu
l'impôt sur le revenu mais du coup on
vous fait un cadeau ceux qui sont encore
plus les plus hauts revenus
oui mais vous n'en avez vous l'assumez
mais je suis pour cent pour bien sûr
c'est 10 % pour tous y compris ceux qui
sont taxés à 45%
madame martichoux jeu l'assument et
j'assume surtout quoi j'assume de dire
stop les seuils en france stop les
usines à gaz
stop les systèmes fiscaux qui sont
tellement compliquées qu'elles arrivent
et ya aucun impôt qui baisse pourquoi
est-ce que je préfère ça parce que ma
priorité c'est d'abord que l'on fasse un
grand signe pour les classes moyennes et
je vais aller jusqu'au bout parce que
comme ça on va bien comprendre et nos
auditeurs comprendre ce que je veux dire
le gouvernement lui propose de dire on
va seulement baissé pour l'entrée dans
l'impôt sur le revenu c'est à dire que
ça va toujours être la même chose
vous avez le malheur de gagner plus de
2000 ou 3000 euros par mois en france
vous êtes considéré comme riche ce que
vous appelez les plus riches
je suis pas d'accord avec ça non c'est
pas les berges sont pas les plus riches
se la logan est le gouver soyons
honnêtes les soignants honnête
qu'est ce que le gouvernement a dit il a
dit que les retraités qui qualifiait de
riches c'était des retraités qui
gagnaient plus de 3000 euros par mois
qui a dit ça rit quand darmanin le
budget quand quand on a expliqué quand
il a expliqué qu'on aurait valoriserait
les retraites que pour les retraités les
plus modestes et pas pour les retraités
privilégié et gens expliqué qu'à partir
de 3000 euros pour un ménage
il fallait pas revaloriser les retraites
voyez les voyez à quel point on oublie
ça rapidement vous rendez compte à quel
point on oublie au fond cette place des
classes comment vous vous répondez aux
sentiments d'injustice fiscale
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a deux
principales injustices fiscales
je voulais dit la première c'est les
classes moyennes
la deuxième c'est la situation fiscale
et la situation du pouvoir d'achat sur
les retraités je sais pas s'il ya
quelque chose qui vous a marqué dans
l'intervention du premier ministre hier
30 minutes un grand discours par un nous
pas un mot sur les retraités rien c'est
d'ailleurs pas étonnant puisque dans le
questionnaire mis en ligne
il n'y avait pas non plus une seule
question sur le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités dans le questionnaire du grand
débat la seule question sur les
retraites elle était sur l'âge de départ
à la retraite la seule j'en vois votre
intermédiaire dubitatif
vous avez raison d'être surprise parce
que je trouve ça moi aussi extrêmement
surpris dubitatifs parce que j'ai pas
compris vous précisément petite
parenthèse rate pardon je voudrais votre
avis sur l'âge de départ à la retraite
parce que il ya une cacophonie
gouvernementale depuis dix jours juste
sur ce sujet vous vous êtes pour le
recul je vais vous répondre je vais vous
répondre très clairement vous permettez
juste d'aller jusqu'au bout de la
première question parce que sinon on en
parlera jamais du pouvoir d'achat des
retraités ont fait deux propositions
très simple le premier ministre a déjà
eu l'occasion
juste pour être précis de dire qu' il
réfléchissait au principe de ré indexé
les pensions notre madame artichauts
l'inflation on va pas jouer au chat et à
la souris
on a eu hier le grand discours du
premier ministre deux conclusions du
grand débat vous n'avez pas un mot sur
les retraités considérer ça comme étant
normal c'est pas normal
maintenant qu'est ce que nous on propose
la première chose qu'on propose c'est
une ré indexation des retraites pour
tous les retraités
là encore même différence le
gouvernement dit uniquement pour les
retraités dit modeste
vous êtes un ménage de retraités vous
êtes à 3000 euros pas de ré indexation
c'est pas normal la retraite c'est pas
un avantage
c'est pas un privilège c'est pas une
tristesse c'est pas un minimum social
c'est le fruit d'une vie de travail la
moindre des choses dans un pays comme la
france c'est la revalorisation du niveau
de l'inflation et la deuxième parce que
ça n'a pas été supprimée on demande la
suppression de l'augmentation de la csg
sur les retraités et on a mis des pistes
d'économies en face maintenant je
réponds à votre question sur l'âge de
départ à la retraite les réformes des
retraites n'ont pas été courageuse par
le passé pourquoi parce que l ont
consisté à demander des efforts toujours
aux mêmes et a laissé de côté au fond
ceux qui ont la capacité manifester de
bloquer le pays moi je suis évidemment
d'accord pour qu'on pose la question de
l'âge du départ à la retraite à une
condition c'est qu'on commence d'abord
et tout de suite pas remettre à égalité
les régimes du public et du privé et par
supprimer tous les régimes spéciaux de
retraite et ensuite on discute de l'âge
du départ à la retraite
mais si cette condition n'est pas
remplie je ne suis pas d'accord parce
que vous pouvez pas avoir certains qui
vont partir à 65 ans et les régimes
spéciaux qui continuent à partir à 56
dans la réforme présentée proposé par le
par le président en pendant sa campagne
il y avait bien la suppression des
régimes sociaux vous est-ce que les
siciliens de suppression d'un compte à
votre question
non non non pas une question c'est beau
jeu mais si pardon
est ce que vous vous ne voulez pas donc
vous positionner sur l'âge de départ à
la retraite sans conditions je vous dis
ça parce que par exemple le président
des hauts de france ally bertrand qui
était notre invité il ya trois semaines
il a été très clair il dit premières
pistes d'économies aller progressivement
vers un départ à la retraite à 65 ans
valérie pécresse présidente ile de
france
je pressens sondés
mino droite pour juin je veux ils disent
ils le disent clairement je peux vous
répondre
et bien moi ce que je vous dis
clairement parce que je sais trop les
réformes des régimes de retraite qu'on a
fait et dont certains que vous avez
mentionné ont contribué par le passé
on commence par les régimes spéciaux et
on commence par ça et je vous le dis
très clairement aujourd'hui non on ne
fait pas maintenant mais maintenant non
madame martichoux fait les forces us si
vous voulez bien de m'écouter y compris
quand on essaie de raisonner en dotant
premier temps on supprime les régimes
spéciaux tout de suite et ensuite
deuxième temps et ils ont parfaitement
raison de ce point de vue on travaille
sur l'âge du départ à la retraite mais
le premier temps j'avais bien compris et
les premiers temps ray merci et le
premier temps c'est bien les régimes
spéciaux de retraite parce que sinon
vous continuerez à laisser subsister les
injustices et c'est ce que les français
ne supportent plus ils disent voilà
quand on me parle des retraites
on demande toujours les efforts même et
on oublie toujours les mêmes et si on
est honnête nous mêmes par le passé on a
commis cette erreur
vous sous-entendez que le gouvernement
ne le fera pas c'est pas que je le
sous-entend c'est que j'ai regardé ce
que propose de le voir delevoye dit on
pourra continuer à avoir des régimes
différents
et là très clairement dit ce qui
signifie en clair que l'on gardera des
régimes différents et donc des avantages
spéciaux
laurent wauquiez dans le jdd dimanche
vous répondait à une question sur le
grand débat et vous dites faire
l'histrion ça ne fait pas une politique
c'est évidemment là dresde emmanuel
macron vous
7 vous le normalien vous utilisez un mot
qui est assez rare mais enfin quand on
regarde le dictionnaire il est assez
clair il n'est pas du tout aimable liste
riant c'est un bouffon qu'est ce que je
veux tu n'en feras on pourrait disserter
sur son application a surtout été
utilisé par molière mais mais mais je
redis on m'avait comédien je vais vous
dire ce que je pense globalement
politique aujourd'hui il ya trop
d'histrion et ce qui me préoccupe sur
cette sortie du grand débat c'est qu'il
faut qu'on garde un cap clair il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été agités
dans tous les sens on finit par plus
voir l'essentiel moi j'ai pas quatre
priorités
j'ai une seule priorité la seule
priorité c'est les baisses d'impôt est
financée par des économies sur la
dépense publique sujet peut-être que je
l'aborderai à travers les questions de
vos auditeurs qui me semble essentielle
pourquoi
et là encore ça n'a pas du tout été
abordée par le premier ministre si
jamais il n'y a pas d'économie sur la
dépense publique il n'y aura aucune
baisse d'impôts durable et ça les
français sont pas dupes
parce que le problème qu'on a eu au
cours des deux ans qui viennent de
s'écouler
c'est qu'on a baissé certains impôts
pour en augmenter d'autres à l'arrivée
les prélèvements obligatoires n'ont pas
véritablement baissé
si jamais on n'a pas le courage
d'expliquer simplement l'avons fait des
économies pour financer nos baisses
d'impôts on ne changera rien dendre
lestrille ans et pour tous ceux qui nous
gouvernent aujourd'hui éventuellement et
qui ne sont pas précis sur les efforts à
faire c'est ce que vous nous avez dit un
mot des européennes avant qu'on fasse
une pause pour revenir devant les
auditeurs le chef de file des sénateurs
et l'air bruno retailleau au grand jury
a mis la barre assez haut
il ya quelques semaines il a dit il faut
faire plus de 15 pour ça on n'est pas
condamné à faire 14 15%
on peut aller très au delà vous partager
cet objectif
d'abord ce qui me fait plaisir c'est que
vous savez j'ai fait un choix qui était
fort et clair avec un trio une jeune
génération une nouvelle droite
au début ça n'a pas été facile y compris
dans ma famille politique on a eu des
critiques mais je suis content de voir
que maintenant il ya plutôt beaucoup
d'adhésions de l'ambitieux objectif que
voulu fixer vous fixé moi je fixe comme
seul objectif concret aux français un
choix et qu'ils ne soient pas
prisonniers entre une alternative entre
d'un côté marine le pen est ko
ou de l'autre côté un président de la
république qui les a déçus sur les
européennes pour dire oui à l'europe
ils ont un autre choix c'est celui qu'on
propose enfin des objectifs chiffrés
simple ma réponse simple vous nous avez
fixé des pronostics et les sondages qui
nous donnaient entre 8 et 10
ce qu'on va vous faire mentir ces les
pronostics le plus haut possible
pourquoi seulement 15 pourquoi seulement
12 le plus haut possible
à tout à l'heure à 8h20 que les
auditeurs yves calvi 823 merci laurent
wauquiez d'être resté avec nous pour
dialoguer avec les auditeurs d'rtl au 32
10 ils peuvent vous appelez plus au
64900 comme matin pour les questions sms
je commence par une question sur le site
rtl.fr
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure avec
elizabeth martichoux la baisse des
impôts précisément ma conviction c'est
qu'on peut pas baisser les impôts si on
fait pas des économies moi c'est ce que
j'ai fait dans ma région je m'occupe de
la région vers rhône-alpes on est la
seule région fusionnée qui a réussi à
faire des économies
en trois ans on a fait 300 millions
d'euros d'économies et une fois que j'ai
fait les économies
j'ai pu baisser les taxes et on est la
seule une des seules régions de france
avoir réussi à baisser ses taxes sur
quoi ont été faites des économies
les économies on les a faites sur quoi
on les a faits d'abord sur la complexité
administrative par exemple à dire je
vais vous donner un exemple très simple
quand on était un euro pour financer un
permis de conduire pour un jeune on
s'est aperçu qu'il y avait tellement de
complexité administrative de dossiers de
lourdeur de commissions de comités que
l'arrivée sur un euro il y avait 90
centimes qui partait dans l'instruction
des dossiers 10 centimes seulement qui
arrivait vraiment un jeune pour l'aider
à passer son permis de conduire on a
tout simplifier on avait par exemple une
vingtaine d'agents ce qui s'occupait des
questions économiques
on en a plus qu'une quand on était dans
le secteur de l'agriculture bio il y
avait tellement d'intermédiaire que à
l'arrivée on n'avait plus d'argent
qu'ils allaient sur les structures
intermédiaires que sur les agriculteurs
donc tout cela correspond aussi à des
suppressions de postes effectifs oui et
il faut l'assumer
parce que vous faites pas d'économie
sans faire des économies donc ça veut
dire clairement que à l'arrivée j'ai une
collectivité qui a des dépenses de
fonctionnement qui sont moins élevés je
vais aller jusqu'au bout même du sujet
dans ma région et je propose ça au
niveau national le temps de travail
était pas 35 heures quand je suis arrivé
j'ai considéré que c'était pas normal
donc on a augmenté le temps de travail
pour faire passer tous les
fonctionnaires de la région à 35 heures
et ils ont adhéré ça pas été facile au
début
ce que j'ai mis en contrepartie c'est
aussi des primes au mérite qui
permettait de valoriser l'implication
des agents et sain c'est aussi à partir
de ses idées qu'on a nous mis en oeuvre
des propositions qu'on fait au niveau
national c'est quoi un d'abord
augmentation du temps de travail avec en
contrepartie des primes au mérite pour
reconnaître ceux qui sont impliqués
deuxième élément suppression de tout ce
qui a augmenté au cours des dernières
années
c'est pas les services publics qui ont
augmenté c'est toute cette bureaucratie
en france qui est quand même notre
spécialité et qui coûte très cher et la
troisième chose parce qu'on a trop peu
souvent le courage de rentrer dans le
détail c'est les questions de
simplification de nos usines à gaz
administrative
juste un chiffre notre système social à
faire tourner et administrativement
france coûte 20% en moyenne plus cher
qu'en allemagne sans couplée à des
mesures qui permettent de remettre plus
d'équilibré entre le travail et
l'assistanat on peut arriver à faire 20
milliards d'euros d'économies on va tout
de suite donné la parole à hervé qui est
conseil municipal il nous appelle du
loiret et à lui-même vous poser sa
question bienvenue hervé nous vous
écoutons oui bonjour messieurs merci de
cette parole voilà oui j'habite un petit
village l'a fait leur meilleur mois à
côté de montargis un joli petit village
de 800 habitants
mais voilà depuis maintenant trois ou
quatre ans notre médecin habituel est
parti en retraite bien sûr et nous
cherchons désespérément un médecin donc
une petite réflexion si vous me le
permettez en 12 secondes
est-ce qu'il serait peut-être une
apporter une réflexion sur le fait
d'accompagner financièrement un jeune
docteur en médecine sortant de
l'internât pour s'installer à la
campagne à savoir le temps d'avoir une
patientèle livre de ce nom lui
permettant de vivre aider financièrement
nous avons les
le local nous avons absolument tout et
nous cherchons désespérément voilà je
vous remercie en tout cas de 2,2 me
donne une réponse c'est nous qui vous
remerciant hervé la question est simple
c'est les déserts médicaux en france et
est ce qu'on peut par exemple quasiment
financer les jeunes médecins pour qu'ils
s'installent réponse rapide s'il vous
plaît il ya un mois on lançait une
maison de santé en ardèche à côté
d'aubenas où un homme est grand plaisir
c'est qu'on avait une médecin qui était
encore un train de faire ses études et
qui était en stage qu'on avait financé à
côté d'un médecin qui s'apprêtaient à
partir en retraite
oui avec une transition très bonne
proposition d'hervé moi ce que je
propose c'est que l'on puisse financer
des stages aux étudiants en médecine
ça permet de financer leurs études en
échange ils font leur stage en zone
rurale dans des zones on manque de
médecins
et comme ça on prépare les transmissions
entre ceux qui partent à la retraite et
les nouvelles générations et dans le
loiret il ya notamment députés le truc
est en train de les médecins
s'installent et moi je pense pas parce
que je suis attachée à l'exercice
libéral de la médecine
par contre il faut favoriser qui se fait
avec de l'argent public puisqu'il dépend
de la sécurité sociale 1 je le rappelle
ouais mais je vais vous dire exactement
ce que je pense si on transforme tous
les médecins fonctionnaires je suis pas
sûr qu'à l'arrivée notre médecine se
portera mieux je suis attaché au choix
et à la médecine libérale
bonjour patrick vous nous appelez du
département de la vienne et vous allez
pouvoir poser votre question à laurent
wauquiez
messieurs vous parliez tout à l'heure
n'était pas contre l'allongement du
temps de travail parce que la
démographie est un tel que il va falloir
financer les retraites et la dépendance
mais en parallèle que vous prévoyez
quelque chose pour améliorer les petites
retraites des travailleurs indépendants
je suis je vais parler de mon cas mais
c'est le cas de tous mes collègues quand
vous avez cotisé quarante quatre années
en taux plein et que au bout de ses 44
années vous touchez 856 euros est-ce que
c'est très normal quelque part d'un état
aujourd'hui et est ce que vous prévoyez
il te met lloret ce cas juste pour
donner un caractère plus précis à votre
question votre profession patrick du
fromager vous étiez fromage est donc un
indépendant elle a tout à fait écouter
le récit bien sûr
la réponse de laurent wauquiez mon frère
moi cotisent au régime des indépendants
quand je vois ce à quoi il a le droit et
le niveau des cotisations qui peignent
c'est très clair qu'on a un problème d'
injustice en france et c'est ce à quoi
j'ai fait référence dans les chances
qu'on a eue avec madame martichoux sur
les inégalités qu'on a dans nos régimes
de retraites entre le système du public
et le système du privé c'est pour ça que
la première chose que je demande c'est
qu'il puisse y avoir une égalité entre
le système du privé du public
je me permets de rajouter quelque chose
par rapport à votre question le système
d'aidé des indépendants est un système
qui parce qu'il a été plutôt bien géré a
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
réserves
ma crainte c'est que dans la réforme qui
est prévu en ce moment et ça ce serait
vraiment le compte de l'injustice on
aboutisse à mettre la main sur l'argent
qui a été mis de côté dans les régimes
du privé pour financer les déficits
qu'on a sur les régimes spéciaux est
gelée dit dans une interview que j'ai
fait ce dimanche dans le jdd il faudra
être très vigilant pour que l'argent qui
a été mis de côté dans des régimes du
privé et qu'ils ont été correctement
gérés ne servent pas à combler les trous
d'autres régimes et ça c'est un des
points de grosses vigilance qu'on aura
nous sur la réforme des retraites mais
pour répondre clairement à votre
question oui évidemment la seule réforme
des retraites courageuse c'est celle qui
permet de mettre à égalité les droits
qu'on a dans le public et dans le privé
vous avez bien dit tout à l'heure au
micro d' elizabeth martichoux
suppression avant toute chose de tous
les régimes spéciaux de retraite
bien sûr épais et comme je dis ça qu'on
commence par ça bien sûr et comme je dis
sans je le dis aussi y compris on
commence par ceux des parlementaires et
des élus
vous serez moins les risques de ne
jamais finalement reculer l'âge de leur
traitement en mettant une condition
préalable
c'est un peu ce qu'on entend non madame
artichauts je pense qu'au contraire ce
qu'il faut entendre c'est nous prenons
plus le risque de ne pas remettre à
égalité les français devant la retraite
stop ça suffit on a tellement fait de
réforme des retraites dans lesquels on a
repoussé l'âge de départ sans jamais
avoir le courage de commencer à mettre à
égalité les différents régimes de
retraite on commence par ça vous avez
quand même conscience que c'est un
renoncement à l'engagement de l'état qui
engage un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires qui ont choisi des voies
parfois
le travail parce qu'ils auraient aussi
cette ces régimes spéciaux mais pardon
mais cette question elle s'oppose pour
tout le monde les gens quand ils ont
commencé à travailler et qu'ils qu'ils
anticipaient de partir à 62 ans si on
leur dit que finalement il faut partir à
65 ans c'est un changement et donc il
faut le faire de façon respectueuse
il faut mettre les délais qui permettent
de le faire mais enfin ça me semble un
moment où on parle beaucoup d'injustices
dans notre pays
ça fait partie des injustices qu'à un
moment il faut arrêter c'est donc michel
qui vous interroge maintenant leur
vautier bonjour michel ne vous écoute on
entendre concernant les élections
européennes
oui je suis élue de toute la nuit je
suis président mais groupe l'est
républicain
je vois beaucoup de monde et les gens de
banlieue et la pauvre monsieur demande
pourquoi ils voteront pour monsieur bel
ami franchement ils me disent tous
qu'ils ne représentent pas du tout alors
je ne voudrais pas qu'ils soient attirés
par marie le pen en l'occurrence
donc qu'est ce que vous pourriez vous
verrez comme réponses à leur apporter
c'est pas facile il est en train de vous
dire votre candidat n'est pas le bon en
tout cas dans mon dans mon département
qu'est ce qu'on fait d'abord vous savez
un candidat pour que ce soit un bon
candidat il faut pas juste que ce soit
un des cadres de chaque électeur
l'objectif c'est pas que ce soit un
candidat rural qui parle au rural que ce
soit un candidat urbain qui parle
rurbains candidats des quartiers qui
parle au quartier ça c'est typique de ce
que moi j'aime pas dans ce qui est
devenu la république en découpe tout en
tranchée en catégorie quelle est la
force de françois xavier bellamy par
rapport aux européennes est ce que
proposent les autres
marine le pen et nicolas dupont aignan
c'est la déconstruction de l'europe il
suffit de dire vous regardez de l'autre
côté de la manche ce qui passe au
royaume uni pour comprendre que cette
voie là est une impasse
elle vous dit bellamy ça passe pas dans
son département alors peut-être que ça
passe ailleurs mais que lui répondez
vous c'est précisément ce que je lui
réponds c'est que voter pour marine le
pen c'est encore plus de difficultés
encore plus de pertes d'emplois encore
plus de perte de pouvoir d'achat
dans un département comme la seine saint
denis où déjà la question de l'emploi
est difficile et bien la déconstruction
de l'europe serait une folie de l'autre
côté je pense que la liste que propose
emmanuel macron c'est toujours plus de
cette europe qui n'a pas marché c'est
plus d'élargissement ils veulent faire
entrer les pays des balkans
la roumanie dans schengen c'est plus de
bureaucratie bruxelloise propose de
créer eux créent beaucoup d'agents
supplémentaires nous au fond si vous
voulez défendre notre liste qu'il faut
leur dire si on veut retrouver l'europe
qu'on aimait celle qui marche est celle
où il n'y avait pas trop de pays autour
de la table une europe qui était capable
de défendre ses produits et ses
entreprises et dans votre secteur aussi
une europe capable de défendre ses
frontières
il ya deux propositions très importantes
que porte françois xavier
la première c'est d'abord une barrière
écologique quand des produits sont
fabriqués dans des pays qui ne
respectent pas nos règles
environnementales
on met une taxe écologique à l'entrée
pour les importations et la deuxième
règle qu'on souhaite mettre en place
c'est ce qu'on veut c'est une double
protection de nos frontières
une protection européenne et une
protection nationale
voilà et pour s'assurer la version
courte michel c'est donc vous répondez à
vos adhérents c'est marine le pen ou
bellamy donc mieux vaut bellamy du point
de vue lors de la toute dernière
question qui vous sera posée
ayman d'elisabeth si carole gones sur
rtl hier dans un document exceptionnel
on a appelé à emmanuel macron elle
demande à ce que l aide à ce que par
dans le président l'aide à faire sortir
son mari frison et surtout et avoir un
procès équitable
est ce que la france doit intervenir au
plus haut niveau pour aider carlos ghosn
réponses courtes s'il vous plaît moi je
ne crois pas qu'on doive intervenir et
faire des interférences
honnêtement les révélations qu'on a
laisse quand même le sentiment de
quelqu'un qui a fini par considérer que
tout lui était permis et qu'il était en
situation d'impunité
je pense qu'il est jugé en chapeau s'il
a exigé au japon il doit être jugé au
japon il clame son innocence encore dans
une vidéo ce matin et moi je n'ai aucun
des participants des gouvernements qu'on
dirige et renault avec lui y âge c'est
cg aucun élément là dessus précis et
concrets mais quand on voit les
révélations sur les mariages sur son
train de vie sur la façon dont il ya une
confusion entre l'argent de nissan et
son argent personnel
c'est quelque chose qui me met mal à
l'aise et en tout cas pour répondre
clairement à votre question
si il n'ya et si l'application du droit
fait qu'il ait jugé au japon il doit
exiger au japon la france n'a pas à
intervenir nous dit vous dans le cas de
carlos ghosn auprès du japon merci
laurent wauquiez d'avoir merci à vous et
avec les auditeurs d'rtl et d'avoir
répondu aux questions d'elisabeth
martichoux